one two three four
we've had 25 albums as sparks
and so with our
albums as the band we always try each
time to figure out how to
do something that's really provocative
and modern one way that we found to
really challenge ourselves was to try to
do a narrative project we had done one
project in the past was called the
seduction of ingmar bergman which was
commissioned by the swedish national
radio which was a radio music drama
so we were really excited about working
in that format in a way and so this was
the next kind of logical step to try to
do something that would be a movie
musical the origin of the story really
was what if there were a baby who could
sing and even in an operatic way
and then building around that
[Music]
nine years ago we had met
leo's carex friend of ours had said hey
would you like to meet leo so we said oh
it'd be a real real honor because he had
used one of sparks songs a song called
how are you getting home in his last
film called holy motors he was kind of a
real kindred spirit him being from the
film world and us being from the music
world and that we shared certain ideals
about the creative process so we sent
him this project and he said wow this is
something
really interesting and then we got an
email from saying you know i'd really
like to direct this as my next film and
then all of a sudden we said wow that's
pretty astounding
once leos did get involved he kind of
wanted to help us in himself to refine
the characters a bit more and to make
them a bit richer and more detailed than
maybe they were in our original version
as the process progressed we had
discussions about our kind of shared
sensibility of what movie musicals
should be leos has always had a musical
segment in every single one of his films
it's always a really strong segment and
so we had faith that if this were
extended to an entire film of music and
singing that it would be something that
would work
the song so may we start that begins a
net was something that was there
even before we met laos we envisioned
a scene where it would be outside of the
film like fourth wall where it isn't
really a part of the sensibility of the
film the people that are involved with
the film speaking about the film and
their their fears that maybe the budget
isn't large enough or their worries
about their preparation or the the ego
problems of the
may be writers
the budget is large but still it's not
enough so may we start may we start may
we may we know
and laos is there he has the first lines
it's actually his daughter that's uh in
the opening shot as well who is acting
as though she's maybe an assistant and
so he says in french
it's going to start now
so
we start
we have a kind of unique way of doing
the music and
the script in at the same time we don't
separate the two for us the music is so
integral to the whole process we knew
that that the movie was going to have
a broad range of styles but we wanted
the opening number to be really bright
and it's a song stylistically that's
more in keeping with what we do as
sparks he encouraged the
sparks band members to get some really
irritating uh you know
feedback from their guitars and their
stomping on their pedals and all
and he was really encouraging them to do
it louder and more abrasive
it kind of
really adds a level of intrigue to the
beginning
[Music]
the scene was shot in village recorders
in west los angeles and it's a really
famous studio leos actually chose that
studio because it had access once you
leave the studio you're on the busy
boulevard and he wanted to get that kind
of color
it was one of the final scenes that was
shot oddly enough most of the movie was
shot in in europe leos just felt it
absolutely needed to be done in los
angeles because he wanted to have the
exterior shot as we're all walking along
santa monica boulevard so we're happy
that they um transported everybody here
for that final scene it was it is really
amazing that there was no cuts in that
in that shot at all it was all
one
continuous
shot it was pretty bold
i think we did 18 takes of it it was
demanding for us
the two of us non-actors to be told okay
you've got to put on your jacket tie
your scarf as you're getting up and walk
outside and you've got to hit
that staircase where adam driver and
marion kotiar are both descending at
exactly the right time of the song so
that we can then all head out onto the
street actually we recorded uh just
about everything right here and when we
went to um to shoot the scene leos
wanted to have it actually be a real
live performance so it is the band
playing so may we start
[Music]
so may we start
it's time to start
i'm
one other thing that laos really
insisted on with with the act all of the
actors was that they
sing
sing their their parts live while it's
being
shot which was something that you know
something that doesn't always happen in
movie musicals a lot of things are are
lip sync but he he really insisted that
to give it give it more of a a realism
to their
[Music]
may we not performances
to close all the doors and let's begin
the show the exits are clearly marked
thought you should know the offers are
here so let's not show this day
[Applause]
they'd live with that song the actors
for for a long time and the song so may
we start was actually rehearsed at that
point to see what marion and and adam
were capable of singing or if there were
any revisions that needed to be made for
any reason like the key or anything and
so when we got to los angeles i think
everybody was really well prepared
when leos really accepted that it could
be a part of the final film we were so
thrilled that a thing that we had
envisioned for for so long could
actually be a
a part of the film when it played at
cannes just because there hadn't been
the festival the year before and
everybody was in such an
exuberant mood so maybe we started
almost became
like the unofficial anthem this year
it can we really love the scene but then
to see how it hits
an audience is really something where
you just have no idea because we're
working in so such isolation during the
the whole process to see the audience
cheering when you know each character
appears and
and to be surprised that we were in the
you know kind of the first
people you really see singing in the in
the in the movie and all it was just for
us was really thrilling
so may we start
[Music]
you